there is only one brother régil velasco
president of the institute of thought
strategic now idea the first pin
thong young in mexico and now
coordinator of one million young people by
mexico besides being part of the
new and larger community has been
a huge pleasure to participate in this
meeting of the world economic forum for
latin america an extraordinary space
of dialogue where we have been able
exchange ideas points of view on
different topics on their subjects that are
so important in the region and in the
world especially with the perspective of
see how we can each from our
own trench provide part of the
solution as professor klaus says
schwab the forum in this dialogue
stakeholders finally we are one we are
complex societies integrated with
different profiles with a logo study
together we can really generate
much more creative solutions
innovative for the different problems
an invitation to all young people to
learn more about the waists of
forum everything that is given is worth it
be aware for the penalty of participating and
especially worth it if the team
because now more than ever our
roots need our work
decided they need us to assume our
responsibility that we understand that the
future is not stopped we can
include it that's great news and
they remember something else that is very
important despite the problems
always when there is the will everything
it can change because we have the certainty
that there is nothing absolutely nothing
that can not be modified everything depends
of us so it is an invitation
to all the people who see us many
thanks for this invitation to the goal
economics of Latin America 2012 in
puerto vallarta thank you very much